seen love on the spectrum no
did you ever watch the undateables yes
but not religiously but i
know the show you know i know the show i
know the premise of the show yes so the
love on the spectrum is literally uh the
australian version of the undeadables
okay
so it's um knowing it's on netflix now
fam oh my god
these um asperger's donnies
they want love and they go through it
fam
these men have got autism the deep
autism
first of all i'm i'm slightly concerned
i might have autism work
all these men love anime
every single one of them loves anime
that's not a symptom of autism fam isn't
it if you watch the show
you'll second guess yourself
i was thinking why did i love anime
don't scare me
i like to be syndrome-free all of them
love anime
there's oh fam i kind of don't know
where to begin there's one guy
called um i actually had to write the
names because i actually watched it a
little while ago
um what's his name
can't find it no i found it okay there
was a chinese guy in there
oh it was so awkward so they go on the
dates bro and they're so awkward so
obviously the premise is they're looking
for life they're autistic they're
looking for love and they struggle like
with social interaction and stuff like
that
so um this agency sets up dates for them
usually with other people with autism
bro some of the stuff they're so honest
there's one um girl that she's a
bisexual
and she's about autism she went on a
date with another guy who's got autism
okay
and they're just their conversations fam
they're just mad
like she's like cool like what are you
into obviously him
anime this that and i was like cool and
um they were talking talking
and he'd be like cool like what are you
into she was like uh i like girls and
boys
he's like swear down and they don't know
what to do with that information
and they're just like cool bro um and he
was like yeah yeah yeah i
thought i might be gay one time and then
she was like i'll swear he's like yeah
then i watched gay porn and i was just
like no way
and they talk like they're kids and
they're just like no way
i didn't like that one bit i didn't like
that one bit so i know that's how i know
i'm not gay that would sweet me if i saw
that i was pissing myself if
if i was in the restaurant and i was on
the table next to them i would be
holding my breath
man said i thought i was gay but then i
watched gay porn i was like no
way no way not for me
i didn't like that one bit that's jokes
um so yeah there was that
there was one yet that was trying to um
find love she was bisexual i think she's
like dating a girl
um but then that didn't work out so
she's still looking for love
there's one guy oh my god i can't
remember his name i think it begins with
hey might be adam or something like that
one guy he wants to be in love
there's two guys i want to be in love
this first guy he tries to patent
the nicest dates he's just so obsessed
and he's always talking to his mom and
dad
basically oh he he loves his younger
brother his younger brother doesn't have
autism
okay and his younger brother he's like
um his younger brother is called like
michael or something like that he's like
oh like um
i like to see my like he said something
along the lines of like
my younger brother is like god's gift
like he's the golden egg from god
um and i'm just like the [ __ ] on the
bottom of god's shoe
jesus my brother like he's handsome he
really finds it easy to talk to girls
he's always had a girlfriend
he wants to be his younger brother he
admires his younger brother so much
and he hates the fact that he's got
autism and he just struggles to find
love
and like he's always like passionate the
agency lady come to his yard like okay
cool
so what can you tell me about yourself
so we can tell these girls and he's like
you need to tell them brother you need
to tell them i'm passionate
i'm lovely i love my mom i love my dad
like i'm family orientated
like i intend to make this bro fam he's
in his 20s
maybe 30s okay and he's like it lives
with his parents obviously and stuff
like that
and he's like oh i um i'm um what do you
say i love
music and i love romance and yes she's
also
such a nice guy he's the nicest guy and
is i love
romance and i if i was a if
i was a husband i would be 10 out of 10
husband oh blessed
and i was like [ __ ] and they set them up
on this date
and this other lady she's got autism but
she suffers from anxiety bad
so my man patterned the sickest day
fam i've never seen a restaurant like it
it was literally
like a restaurant and like half the
restaurant was made out of glass
and it was hanging off like a cliff so
you'll basically feel like you're
sitting
in the ocean it was sunset so you look
outside next to your
like table out the window and it's just
rocks and sunshine and sea
it was romantic oh wow and he's out
there he got a full
suit you've top you've mentioned this
before have i is this where you said
she said she's not feeling there's i can
take i can change all of this i can
change all of this i
need this literally yeah you said you
mentioned this on this podcast but you
just briefly spoken about oh fam yeah
yeah yeah yeah it wasn't the podcast but
you told me anything on the pod fam
continue
yes she came in he gave her two two
conversations she wasn't feeling it and
she was like i'm not feeling this i'm
not gonna sit and then the camera man
it's them like you need a break
and she was like yeah i need a break
give me a glass of water shoved her off
and he was sitting there like this fab
he was sitting there looking around and
he said ask the producer he was like
david david
is sure and david said yeah it's fine
chill and he's from he's panicking
he's panning his feet whatever done what
have i done and he's looking around like
this is too much and he found me saying
that
why did i do this why did i do this why
did i do this i've overwhelmed her
family runs over to her and he's like
i'm sorry we don't
we don't have to do this i don't need
this massive date kind of thing we can
just talk we can just be friends she's
like
leave me alone stop family goes back and
sits there
he goes back and slumps in this chair
and he sits there and i was like
oh my boy why'd i have to do that i was
in that restaurant on my date
i would say [ __ ] get up and sit with
him
leave me i'll pay for the whole thing
fam
i want you to hold him buff keep your
chest up my g there's
plenty of yachts out there reminding me
of the dating around show i told you
about when the my man
was feeling when she could say oh we're
just going to be friends on the way home
and he just stumped into the car and the
tear rolled down his eye
i remember that i wanted to scream from
the top of my lines
dating around was live i remember that i
remember that
he got a date though in the end yeah
yeah he's got a lavish guy yeah he was
polite
so polite fam there was another guy on
the show
called kelvin yeah kelvin chinese kid
loves anime obviously he even wrote his
own anime
and drew it in everything yeah he was
sick
he's got so much time on his hand but
he's got like his autism
strong fam like they like he's and he's
like
not to betray he speaks like even though
he grew up in australia
he clearly spent too much time around
his dad because he literally speaks with
like a really strong chinese accent
he's like half chinese half australian
okay you know he's born and bred in
australia okay and he was just like
hello my name is calvin and i am looking
for a date and he just like
and he's got these really thick glasses
and he looks like that
kelvin you look i love kelvin and he
goes on this date and he loves anime so
much
yeah and then like he goes on this date
and this girl's got like this weird and
the thing is
with uh people with autism i didn't
realize because they spend so much time
watching television
they pick up a lot of the themes and
their social etiquette from watching tv
okay so a lot of them have american
accents even though they're not american
okay because they watch so much american
tv i never knew that
neither did i still watch that but i
thought it makes perfect sense okay
because i remember that when i was a kid
my friend when i was a kid i watched so
much tv
movies and tv is all i did so and
literally it would like
so some of the stuff i would say will
come out like america um but anyway
i was watching it and then he goes on
this date he takes her to a
um oh what's the type i can't remember
what the type of restaurant is called
you know like benihana
where they cook the chefs in front of
they're doing all the yucky yeah yeah
that's it
takes it to a taping spot yeah and then
he sits down there and he even knows
that he's chinese but he's learned
japanese from watching anime
dang so everything he's sitting down
he's like itadakimasu
family he talks to the chef in japanese
he's
like fam he's the perfect guy and he
sits down on the phone he's like oh
hello like what do
what do you like to do and she was like
she just like she speaks
this is how she speaks well she
literally sits like this and her neck's
like tucked in and she's got american
accent just because she watches so much
american tv but she's australian she's
australian and she just brings she
brings her nintendo switch
and she's just sitting there playing it
she's like i'm just gonna play my video
games
and she sits there playing it like while
he's talking he's like
okay and because that they don't know
how to socially interact
the lady from the day in agency has
talked them through step by step
you ask her what she likes to do she's
gonna say this or this
and you're gonna have to say this so
when it veers from the plan that they
set out he doesn't know what to do
he's looking around i wouldn't know what
to do and he's looking around like
he's like okay and he sits there and
he's like you can see his eyes
look up trying to remember like what's
the next step he's like
um do you like anime and then she's like
um
no not really and then she just turns
and plays again he's like
and um
there's one bit yeah there's one bit
where um
she um so she's playing there and then
um he's like oh okay
um i watched lots of anime but um i
can't watch
um he says another enemies are i can't
watch this because it's got adult themes
and i was like oh that's too cute it's
certain anime's not to watch because
it's got pornographic content
um she's like cool yeah like i said i
don't really like anime yeah
let's stop talking about i don't like it
he's like okay cool and then um he's
like oh um
he's like what do you like to do she was
like oh i just like like to sit on my um
this is a dreaded thing so she said i'd
like to sell my computer right mm-hmm
but she the way she said it was she said
competitor
so it was this five seconds of
interaction was the weirdest and
funniest and most
shocking piece of content i've ever seen
in the space of a back and forth for
five seconds
so she's like yeah i just like to play
video games with my competitor and then
he's like
what did you say and then he was like
competitor
and then she was like what she had no
idea that she's a competitor
so when he said competitor she had no
idea what she's what he's on about
okay and because he's chinese yeah she
was like she literally said this
look i'm not trying to be racist but
what the hell is a competitor
i can't understand you
and man doesn't know confrontation like
that
kelvin doesn't know confrontation like
that so a normal person would be like
excuse me [ __ ] you said professor don't
talk to me about racist i don't
understand why words come out your
[ __ ] mouth
let me get the bill get out of here
that's what a normal man would say
my girl said i'm sorry i'm not being
racist yet but
what's that
he was flabbergasted dumbfounded
he was like what what
fam he was baffled i said
what and he was trying to wrap the whole
convo in his head
i was sitting there no what is going on
and he was out what nah and he just said
no come and then he finally established
like
did you say computer originally she was
like yeah and he was like
cool and he just like at that point he
had to brush it off had enough
he had enough and at the end like he was
like yeah she's cool but uh she doesn't
like anime so i'm not i'm not into it
and i was like gang you shouldn't be
[ __ ] here
she's a [ __ ] that's right you get so
defensive of these man
so definitely imagine fam there's
another guy called mark mark is suave
yeah he's a white guy and he walks like
this proper slow
but he's not even attention he just
walks like this and he's the most polite
gentleman you've ever met and he'll go
on a date and just like
and he talks like this he's like oh
hello
he hasn't got the deepest form of autism
yeah but like
he just showers yet with compliments
okay
showers them with compliments and he's
like oh yes
ah hello yes and then like he sat down
with one coffee date it was one yeah
and um he was like ah if you don't mind
me saying you are just so
beautiful she wasn't he's like you're
just so beautiful like i'm so happy
that you agreed to come out and have a
date with me that's so nice
fam mark oh my days if i was a yeah i'd
marry mark
that's so nice mark was the nicest dude
and i was like
[ __ ] please find love please finally
i've ride for them fam you're right
infested i was like mark please and he
was like at the end of it he gave her a
kiss on the cheek and he was like
oh would you mind seeing me again like
would you mind
like just giving me the honor of like
another date
and she was like yeah sure that's fine
he's like fantastic like he did she said
so fantastic i can't wait oh my goodness
i can't wait
and he goes home buzzing talks to his
mom and dad he's like 40.
talk to his mum and dad i had such a
great time on this date that's such a
great she was so
nice went another day he loves
dinosaurs he knows everything there is
to know about paleontology
so who takes the yet on a second date
she was like oh
to the museum and he was like yeah i'm
really into paleontology
and yeah she's got autism as well but
she ha
hers is really mild yeah she's like
paleobot and he's like paleontology and
she's like
sorry what's that word he said
paleontology
and she was like painting
and she's she got such a mild form of it
that like if you met her she thought
she's a tiny bit like
kind of quirky and weird no idea would
you ever think that she's got autism
okay
and the fact that she couldn't say
paleontology was irking him to a point
that he couldn't
bear but he was still trying to be
suffered because he was so bad yeah yeah
and he was like
paleontology she was like
his spectrum is moving
his spectrum is shaking he doesn't know
if he loves her anymore fam and he's
like what is this
he's thinking what is this i'm trying to
share my passions this guy can't say
paleontology
she's grown and he's oh you can see his
head doing backflips
and he just has to kind of brush it off
and it's like this is velociraptor this
is this isn't this
my girl's yawning fam oh they can't hide
their true feelings these man yeah of
course she's yawning
and you can see he's just like
and he's paying her compliments and at
the end fam
he was like i just had such a great time
with you thank you so much for sharing
my passion
i'm really happy you agreed to come with
me to the museum so i could tell you
about
what like really um really i'm
passionate about and like my love of
dinosaurs and paleontology
thank you so much it's such a beautiful
day thank you for having ice cream with
me
i'm so happy you agreed to meet me again
like i am
really really like you and i was
wondering if you'd like to go on another
date with me
like it would really really make me
happy and she was like nah
to be honest like i think we're just
friends
fam and he was like you can't dismiss no
no no he did it
but you could
and then he just beat the [ __ ] out of
her oh
[ __ ] you said 90 you were like i thought
you fully clutched these feet that's
what i did
that's what i did thumb she was like now
if he would be friends and he was inside
his eyes squinted fab and he was like
okay that's painful he took it in
his heart and his chest and his sternum
and he swallowed it and he was like okay
yeah damn friends fantastic i love
would love to have you as a friend i'll
be honored to have you as a friend
and his dad was waiting to pick him up
um he walked over and i was like hey dad
he literally said hey dad the dad was
like how did it go and he was like ah
not great she's not interested in
anything with me
oh that's annoying man fam he's the nice
she was butters as well she was ugly as
well
i don't want to be like [ __ ] her bruv
you're too good for her anyway
[ __ ] thing i was so angry
that hurts my soul fam that hurts myself
the whole show is i'm so happy it's only
like four or five episodes
because it's just it's too much the
stress it puts you through fam
is really really hard